la pandémie du courant d'un virus met à
mal les décisions du gouvernement masque
annoncé inutile puis rendue obligatoire
pour le déconfinement absence massive de
thèse fermeture tardive des frontières
confinement lancer sur le tard l'état at
il fauté dans la gestion de la crise
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir et pour en parler nous sommes en
direct avec fabrice di vizio avocats des
professions de santé à l'origine
d'ailleurs de plusieurs plaintes contre
le gouvernement à ses côtés philippe
bessette président de la fédération des
syndicats pharmaceutiques de france
bonsoir à vous aussi merci d'être avec
nous première question messieurs vous
avez sans doute écouté edouard philippe
aujourd'hui le 11 mai évidemment plan de
déconfinement sauf si les français
manifestement se relâche
première question est ce que cela vous
semble crédible ses premiers pas vers le
déconfinement dans une semaine
mon sens aller mais c'est finalement
carl et on voit qu'il pose de graves
problèmes des gens qui sont isolées pour
on a parlé des personnes âgées en ehpad
qui ne peuvent plus voir personne n'en a
parlé de nombreux autres problèmes de
santé des renoncements aux soins de gens
qui n'osent pas aller chez leur médecin
en termes de santé c'est clair qu'il
faut il et allemandes en eux toute
précaution aller vers des compliments et
bien sûr en termes économiques
on sait pas vraiment mon sujet en tant
qu' en tant que pharmacien mais c'est le
sujet de tous en tant que citoyens
évidemment on ne peut pas continuer
longtemps à rester tous chez soi non
plus à falloir apprendre la prudence
apprendre des gestes d'hygiène
donc on a vu qu'on avait découvert à
l'occasion de cette épidémie mais qui
seront très utiles pendant tout le
rallye que notre notre vie difficile une
réaction
moi pour ma part ce que je considère
c'est que nous prend le problème à
l'envers
vous dis il faut bien sortir du
déconfinement évidemment qui concerne
déconfinement mais peut-être qu'on n'est
pas obligé si vous voulez d'en sortir
n'importe comment c'est à dire que c'est
toujours le même problème depuis le
départ on est guidé par un élément qu'on
a oublié c'est l'incertitude
on ne sait rien alors je sais bien que
certains spéculent sur l'absence de
deuxième règle et tant mieux si c'est
pas le cas
mais la politique c'est espérer le
meilleur et préparer au pire et c'est
exactement ce qu'on ne fait pas on a
train de m'expliquer qu'il faut ce dès
qu'on finit bien sûr qu'il faut ce dès
qu'on fini mais on est en train de
m'expliquer qu'il faut que tout le monde
est un masque pour les confiner parce
que vous pensez que l'on se mette au
monde aura un masque normes il faut
arrêter cinq minutes on est sur une
décision qui est purement politique qui
est purement arbitraire on a dit le 11
mai comment on aurait pu dire le 10 ou
le vin et la vérité effectivement c'est
que concrètement bas on n'est pas prêt
et on sera pas plus près sous réserve
qu'on soit réellement des confiné longue
mais parce que je vous rappelle quand
même
qui a dit qu on réévaluera les choses au
7 mai alors le relais masculin justement
c'est un peu le sujet sensible en ce
moment chez les pharmaciens infinite 17
est ce que justement vous faites partie
de ces personnes qui ont été choqués on
a vu renaud muselier tout à l'heure
c'est au néant le mot est faible de ce
stock massif tout d'un coup à
disposition de la grande distribution en
ce sens l'état aurait dû également agir
réguler rédigé réquisitionnées selon
vous oui c'est ce que je les dis enfin
le principe de celle de cette pénurie de
produit n'est pas la régulation la
réglementation est un outil mais là la
chose qui compte c'est le nombre de
masques qui existent sur le territoire
c'est ça qu'ils soient dans les stocks
publics ou privés
le nombre de marques existent je parle
de batteries mérite et la priorisation
de ces masses la priorisation de ces
matches qui doivent aller bon on l'a dit
aux soignants aux aidants familiaux aux
gens qui sont le travail aux côtés
d'autres personnes âgées à lille et
ensuite aux personnes fragiles pour ça
tafer besoin 250 millions de masques
dans le site par semaine dans le circuit
médical personnel
en personne fragile au delà de la de ce
chiffre de 150 millions par semaine le
reliquat doit servir aux des compliments
et ce qui nous a heurtés c'est que les
masques sur les dotations d'état ou sur
le budget de la sécu on va dire ne sont
pas disponibles mois à ce jour je suis
sur une consigne de la direction
générale de la santé du 20 avril pour
lequel je n'ai pas le droit de donner de
base que le stock est à aux personnes
même soir devant une consigne claire
dans les bals sont elles sont stockées
tard je ne parle pas des masses j'ai pu
acheter par les masses du stock et à la
consigne du va'a bridge ehrhoff salomon
donc dire que j'adore la santé c'est
l'interdiction de donner des bases même
sur prescription médicale
ma demande c'est que cette consigne
change et que je puisse donner des
masques en stock et à sur prescription
médicale et aux personnes fragiles dont
je peux je commets parce qu'on la liste
est très précises nous ont dit les gens
qui avec la carte vitale je sais à qui
je dois donner 1 bat chirurgicale
exactement 6 pb cette pardonnez moi
cette question un peu provocatrice
peut-être est-ce que vous savez pas une
sentiment quand même les pharmaciens
vous écouter vous êtes fait anti peut
avoir sur ce coup là parce que voilà je
reviens à mon précédent sujet ses
millions et ses millions de masques ils
sont désormais voilà dans la grande
distribution dans les supermarchés alors
que vous voilà vous semblez encore très
contraint notamment par des directives
gouvernementales comment vous vous
l'expliquer alors on peut on peut se
séparer le sujet en deux mois je vous
parle du stock de l'acheteur public
je vous parle de ce que l'état doit
prendre en charge au titre de la
solidarité nationale
par ailleurs il y a le les achats que
les uns et les autres ont pu faire qui
sont des masques donc des compliments
des mre sont issus des masques
alternatifs et des masques chirurgicaux
il était tout à fait
possible d'acheter depuis donc le 23
mars et qui sont donc en train d'arriver
sur le territoire ce que je ne ce que
l'on pense là dessus c'est que la grande
distri c'est faire un coup de pub pour
notre dos puisqu'en fait jeudi ils ont
annoncé qu'ils avaient de 225 millions
de masques look 170 l'autre 150 millions
et dimanche on a appris qu'en fait en
réalité en stock en stock en france il
n'y en avait que quelques millions et
que le reste et allait arriver un peu
comme ce que nous dit le ministre de la
santé il 60 et nous dit qu'il a acheté 2
milliards 8 de masse de vie des ruines
c'est pareil mais dès 2008 il les a
achetés mais ils sont passés le sol
national
reprenons moi j'ai leit motiv st j'ai
besoin d'abord une dotation pour les
soignants pour les patients sur
ordonnance patients fragiles qui vient
soit du stock est en soi une prise en
charge ont par l'assurance maladie on a
compris le message aura peut-être est
séparé pardonnez moi parce que ça vous
avez la parole à bonbons temps fabrice
des visions longtemps vous lyonnais en
tout temps vous voit la réponse
peut-être à philippe et 7
la réponse est que monsieur bcp de la
sophistique ni plus ni moins monsieur
mais cette est un sophiste c'est à dire
que concrètement monsieur 17 détournent
nos débats vous lui posez effectivement
une question précise et comme il est
embarrassé par la réponse et je vais y
venir
eh bien il vient effectivement faire du
compassionnel et vous expliquer
l'importance de privilégier les
soignants et notamment vous parle des
stocks d'état mais problème dont parle
monsieur muselier notamment et le
problème de la grande distribution n'a
rien à voir avec les stops d'état
l'appel ou plus exactement la tribune
commune des ordres professionnels n'a
rien à voir avec les stocks d'état c'est
pas ça le débat
la grande distribution la vérité
effectivement qu'est ce qu'elle a fait
est là exactement fait ce que les
pharmaciens auraient pu faire depuis le
23 mai qu'on leur a interdit de faire
prétendument au moins c'est à dire que
c'est bien les organes représentatifs de
la profession de pharmacien qui depuis
le 23 vous explique sans discontinuer
que les pharmaciens n'ont pas le droit
d'acheter des masques
c'est depuis effectivement sans
discontinuer depuis le 23 que la
profession explique à ses membres qu'il
est interdite vous vous souvenez de ce
pharmacien monsieur felou je crois sur
le plateau de jean marc morandini qui
expliquait on parle du coup de pub de
leclerc ou que sais-je
comment faut-il qualifié le fait qu'un
pharmacien vienne sur un plateau télé
expliqué que les grossistes répartiteurs
vont braver les interdictions de l'état
est effectivement aller acheter des
masques alors qu'il savait pertinemment
que ces interdictions n'existait pas la
question elle est là quand même
elle est quand même un moment donné on
me parle des dindons de la farce que
sont les pharmaciens bien sûr que les
pharmaciens sont les dindons de la farce
mais on pourrait raisonnablement se
poser la question de savoir à cause de
qui on a littéralement menti à toute une
profession qui raisonnablement et qui de
bonne foi croyez qu'elle n'avait pas le
droit de passer par ces centrales
d'achat pour effectivement acheté des
masques et aujourd'hui comme un forme
comme la profession s'est fait doubler
elle vient vouloir inquisitio n'est les
masques que elle même aurait souhaité
vendre
la vérité c'est que la profession de
pharmacien s'est littéralement fait
avoir que concrètement au nom du john
coleman agrémentent vous avez vu cet
article hier ou des grossistes e10 bas
nous on savait qu'on n'avait pas le
droit
la question qu'il faut poser à monsieur
17 c est ce que oui ou non vous saviez
que vous aviez le droit ou non de vendre
des masques parce qu'il ya qu une
réponse possible
oui ou non si c'est oui bah alors si
vous êtes vous avez le droit de vendre
des masques pourquoi vos pharmaciens les
pharmaciens disait le contraire
et pourquoi
l'ambiguïté a été savamment entretenue
et que l'ordre professionnel a dit non
non non ne dites pas que c'est pas le
cas vous avez fait des communications
vote rendra t des communications sur ce
point non mais pas bien peut-être je
suis l'organisation professionnelle des
pharmaciens je suis dans j'aime bien ce
serait super professionnel alors dans
cette année c'est à ce titre que vous
interroge vous êtes effectivement
responsable de vos écrits alors je vous
interroge avez-vous effectivement passé
la consigne selon laquelle ou au moins
effectivement l'instruction selon
laquelle non les pharmaciens il était
faux de prétendre qu'il n'avait pas le
droit d'acheter des masques et avec vous
effectivement à ceux qui disaient à vos
organisations qui disait que les
pharmaciens n'avez pas le droit de
vendre des masques avez vous répondu
publiquement qu'il en avait le droit
les deux chefs différents oui mais sur
vannes est d'atteindre une chose qu'au
match parce que c'est vrai qu'à question
c'est quand même une réponse est oui
parce que j'ai des écrits donc dès le 2
le 17 avril 17 avril
j'ai envoyé des messages très clairs
pour dire dès le 23 mars chez les
grossistes répartiteurs pour leur dire
qu'ils avaient le droit d'acheter des
masses jusqu'à aller jusqu'à une limite
de cinq millions et que pour le reste il
fallait qu'ils demandent au ministère de
la santé un élément dès le 17 avril
j'ai demandé à mes pharmaciens pour
aider les grossistes répartiteurs dans
l'eure dans leurs achats
je leur ai dit vous avez le droit
d'acheter des masses vous devez acheter
des masques
la question de la vente est une autre
question
la question de la vente la question de
la vente est une autre question que
celle de l'achat je l'avais dit dès le
17 avril tout donné mais vraiment bon et
on en finira sur 7 le schapi des
manifestes que j'aimerais réagir sur un
autre sujet également puisque voix c'est
vrai que la question était est ce que
l'état a commis des fautes
aujourd'hui on a une députée la
république en marche qui a voté contre
ce plan de déconfinement proposé par son
gouvernement
martin
vos nerfs c'est son nom au député du bas
rhin qui explique qu'il ya aucune
stratégie thérapeutique
selon elle on n'a pas laissé tout
simplement les médecins à prescrire les
médicaments qu'ils auraient dû prescrire
qu'il souhaitait prescrire j'avais envie
d'avoir votre avis de pharmaciens
philippe bessette et ensuite celui de
l'avocat qui on le rappelle a posé a
déposé plusieurs plaintes contre le
gouvernement philippe b 7 mois sur ce
sujet du traitement
j'espère qu'il va y avoir un traitement
le plus rapidement possible je suis très
content qu'il y ait de multiples études
qui donne des traitements prometteurs
mon rôle à moi c'est en tant que
pharmacien c'est bien sûr de m'en tenir
à ce que dit la science au jour de la
connaissance de la star dont pour
répondre très précisément à la question
il ya eu donc un départ sur les drogues
si leurs hôtes il
il y a eu un débat sur la nicotine
il y à un débat sur plusieurs grands
petits viraux tous et tous ces débats
qui sont des recherches sont des
recherches sont menées à l'hôpital tant
qu'elles ne sont pas abouti moi je ne
vais pas donner de la nicotine plus de
la plus de la ligue roc cyclo routine
plus d'un antiviral plus des
antibiotiques qui peut qui ont des
beaucoup d'effets secondaires à une
personne qui a peur d'avoir le
coronavirus c'est assez simple donc dès
qu'il y aura je l'espère je l'attends le
plus rapidement possible dès qu'il y
aura un traitement et le fida mans je le
vendais ça ne veut pas dire que l'état
ne doit pas produire au cas où
parce que ce qui serait le pire du pire
c'est que le jour où on dit ce
traitement marche en débatte stocks donc
tant pis il faut lancer les chaînes de
production
parce que si jamais au moment où on dit
ça marche
imaginons les rucks ils ont menti ou à
l'autre et que le ensuite on nous dise
il faut un nombre produire ah ben non
le modef un fabrice di vizio sur ce
point le mot de la fin
c'est qu'on fait pas de la médecine à la
télé c'est tout dire c'est à dire que
concrètement on fait pas de la médecine
députés on n'est pas là pour analyser
les prix quatre ans que je vous dis par
rapport à la députée c'est que
concrètement les médecins ils ont une
liberté de prescription qui l'a même
qu'ils ont toute l'année il ya un débat
autour de la prescription des roxy
chloroquine c'est le seul médicament
soit les médecins ne puisse pas plus le
prescrire et effectivement elle peut le
déplorer a déploré une la vérité c'est
que la science l avance avec prudence et
qu' il faut faire très attention
effectivement à pantin dans une
dictature de l'opinion du ca marche
aujourd'hui bas hiroki chloroquine oui
effectivement c'est une piste
intéressante
incontestablement le tassili du mahb en
est une autre
on a comme le disait monsieur une
multitude effectivement d'essais
cliniques en cours
gardons nous bien de faire de la
médecine de la place des médecins merci
bon concert sera deux mois de la fin
fabrice di vizio philippe vayssettes
d'avoir été avec moi pour ce face à face
merci à vous